alright guys out last two demo just came
out Rob you had a chance to play it do
you love horror games a lot I'm not sure
that I ever see you playing them no I
mean yeah back and forth i guess that
give rob reacting to the resident evil
slim yeah yeah cuz that was fin and I
heard you had a similar experience of
that last two ah yeah alright so
describe this demo I understand it's
pretty short and this is coming from a
game that was supposed to come out this
year but was delayed until 2017 a little
while ago what was it you actually
played what was available uh it just
kind of kicked off and you're just it
man it's it's funny to have played
recently that resident evil demo because
they remind me very much the same thing
where it's like a very much on and maybe
even more so this one it felt very much
on Rails except for certain areas but
anyways you're just this guy immediately
your glasses fall off you trip I think
you're in a plane crash or something
like that and you were on a clearly
bizarre farm where there's some mentally
ill people who like to kill people get
out get out immediately you're just kind
of introduced to them and you are going
through areas again I haven't really
like seen any of the videos or that demo
so this was a fresh for me but you go
into an area it's like super dark where
it's a bed or a barn cradle looking bed
and there's a lot of blood there you go
oh this is where a baby might be and
there's blood not a good sign turn the
corner and there's a pit of dead
children ah so that was surprising I
don't know in general it I could see
where maybe it got delayed in that like
I couldn't I don't know I got a good
understanding of the game okay um in
that if it was on real like the first
half of it was like super on Rails like
you know smart Linear's miss lady Ursula
yeah and you're literally being directed
the entire time so you like turned a
corner is a guy there with an axe it's
like oh I shouldn't go that way
traversing like that that just felt a
little old and
I don't know the moments I prefer for my
horror games sometimes is just like me
having direct control of my circumstance
like there's this part where you hid the
corn fields which is actually pretty
cool there's a bunch of people with
flashlights and you're just like you
know turning your infrared camera off
and on and you're just like avoiding
them that's pretty neat I mean that's me
controlling my outcome those were more
of the tense moments that I wish there
are more of I guess I could say yeah
when it gets more open-ended like that
it's a lot less predictable and you you
and you feel like you have a little bit
more control of your destiny so when
something does go wrong it's kind of
your own fault that's just a jump-scare
at that point right and i can say that i
do get affected by jump scares and then
this one definitely got me there's this
scene in a hallway you like go through a
memory it's a bizarre game like you to
trip out I don't you understand yeah so
I explained the same demo at pax and I
think it's I think it's a bit of an
older demo that's now publicly available
but yeah it's like there's no real
explanation for how this happens but
basically one moment you're on a farm
then you kind of crawl through a hole or
fall down a hole and all of a sudden
you're like in an elementary school
that's never happened you in real life
we're not recently okay um and then yeah
you're kind of making your way through
the halls a elementary school and like
looking through lockers you'll see like
flashes of you know silhouettes in
classrooms and you kind of feel like
there's something near you or behind you
but you can never actually pin it down
and a copy of a call duty game I
remember this and then eventually you
leave the school somehow I can't
remember how you get out of the squad
think you're like pulled through the
ceiling by something you are literally
ripped out of your bone memory so you
like I guess the idea is that you were
just like I would imagine like tripping
out something and then you end up back
on the farm but I know I kind of like
games that will mess with though it's
not fourth wall breaking but they're
very much toying with the medium in a
way it's like well this couldn't happen
in reality but all we have to do in a
game is like when you walk in the next
room it's suddenly a totally different
environment it's so easy to execute but
so unsettling for you as a player like I
appreciate games that are willing to
sort of mess with your head like that
and use that to throw you off and keep
you creeped out that to me is a cool
approaching
wargames i really like when games do
that well so nothing else yet this
particular demo had a great sense of
atmosphere although I agree that
mechanically that I I was also feeling a
little bit lost yeah like I could have
used more dead ends you know like just
dead and opening a door like you know
going around my way that can't open this
door like oh I can't open this door but
clearly this is the only door like I can
open that go through so this is supposed
you know this is where I'm supposed to
go and I think that just got a little
tired and I wanted more of like an
exploration value cuz that's how like oh
whenever I think of horror movies that's
how it kind of always is it's just
someone alone lost searching like yeah
and you're being chased there's no sign
telling them to go one way or another
own or did you know yeah and they
basically have to figure what the hell
to do yeah I'm not opposed to that but I
think you know the dirt there could be
more of a right reason later when this
when this looks like the first like
minutes or a few minutes of that game
it's just one path way up here's a fence
here's a bunch of [ __ ] in the middle
road that you can't get through like
that just like alright well just yeah
you surely can hold my ang where am I
going what's right now talk to me about
the the battery because I understand you
have to collect you know power for your
camera you can use the infrared light
did you find that in this demo that that
actually like had a meaningful no are
you experienced now no my batteries
never I mean oh my better right now when
I got to the the field so [ __ ] yeah but
there was I actually found one lying in
the middle of the cornfield for some
reason which is an odd place for a
better games man there are also double
a's yeah i guess i'm not sure whatever
it takes but it happened to be the exact
battery my camera needed to worked out
but yeah i don't know i think i also was
like rushing it but that's kind of how i
feel like horror game should you know
you mean like you're not like i'm gonna
explore yeah while i'm being chased like
there's reasons for that uh that I felt
like we're untouched more or less I
don't know also having played resident
evil 7 in VR yeah is this the sort of
experience that you imagine might also
translate well mmhmm yeah yeah
absolutely although with that in mind in
the resin 7
do they have like a camcorder anything
that they were like using no ethical and
I don't know yeah just on your own yeah
i think this totally would work is that
yeah those two were very similar yeah um
I could totally see we are being great
for this I'm sure if it was on
PlayStation VR they could just use the
controller as to mimic a camera you just
hold it up that's we getting act like
how how do you account for one another
VR yeah I don't know I I enjoyed it for
the most part I don't know I wonder
you're like why I was delayed because
that this kind of left me like
questioned like what is the this level
design structure of this like I felt
kind of like off well you know it's one
thing to consider like the legacy of the
last game which was kind of a surprise
success it sounded like for red big red
barrels of developer they were almost
taken aback by it and said that spurred
them to continue to make this series you
can imagine that they really want to
nail it otherwise they stand to maybe
lose all of that goodwill that they've
earned so this demo might be just a good
way for them to sort of put something
out there for people who were expecting
the game but won't get it until next
year right yeah and that's definitely
what I think the takeaway is is like you
know you enjoy it for what it is get get
hyped also the ending was a little weird
you know the ending I don't know the
ending do I want to know should we spoil
errs and I mean it's a demo demo so not
breathe hit me what happens uh you run
into one of the fantastic farmers and he
takes an axe to your crotch my crotch
yet specifically you were in the game so
that in VR would be super fun gosh yeah
gianluca into that we were discussing
this yesterday yo who shoots for the
crush that guy oh my god all rights a
lot more about jean-luc than we really
wanted to know oh yeah oh absolutely
yeah all right that's the outlast to
demo did you guys get a chance to play
it let us know in the comments below and
are you still looking forward to the
game despite his linearity